[Musik]
Wahlkampf in Niedersachsen Christian
Lindner muss eine Zitterpartie fürchten
die Umfragen für die FDP schwanken von
fünf bis sieben Prozent sollte die
Partei aus dem Landtag fliegen es wäre
ein Desaster für die FDP und für ihn
persönlich ein gestörtes Verhältnis
zwischen FDP und Wähler warum profitiert
die Partei nicht von der Ampel für ihn
liegt es nicht an den Liberalen
in diesen Zeiten das merken wir Gerät zu
einer Position der Mitte der Freiheit
der Selbstverantwortung unter Druck von
rechts und von links doch der Wähler
gotiert gerade nicht den selbst
ernannten Weg der Mitte die beiden
letzten Landtagswahlen frappieren
schlecht für die FDP in
Nordrhein-Westfalen abgestürzt auf 5,9
Prozent in Schleswig-Holstein auf 6,4
zweimal mehr als halbiert die FDP kämpft
für längere AKW-Laufzeiten und
Schuldenbremse aber viele hadern mit der
Ampel ich denke das ist auch noch ein
Gewöhnungsprozess ist bei vielen auch
unserer Anhänger zu sehen dass wir in
einem Bündnis sind das ja durch mit SPD
und Grünen zwei linke Parteien als
Partner hat für die FDP und da sind
natürlich auch Dinge dabei die wir dann
in so einer Koalition eingehen müssen
die nicht originär liberale Politik sind
Stralsund hier hoch im Norden hat sich
nun der erste Kreisverband mit einer Art
Brandbrief Luft gemacht die SAP
Kommunalpolitiker distanzieren sich von
der Ampel Teile der Bundesregierung sein
katastrophal gescheitert sie meinen vor
allem die Wirtschaftspolitik sie meinen
vor allem Robert Habeck aber sie gehen
auch mit dem eigenen fdp-justizminister
hart ins Gericht er segne willkürlich
beschlossene Freiheitsbeschränkung ab
wenn ich keine Zahlung keine Daten keine
Fakten habe dann kann ich so ein
Infektionsschutzgesetz nicht durchlassen
geht in meinen Augen nicht da sahen sich
viele fdp-
was hat eigentlich mit liberaler Politik
eben nicht so viel zu tun der
spd-gesundheitsminister wollte
eigentlich viel mehr der liberale
Justizminister weniger aber die FDP
trägt nun mit was das eigene Klientel
schwer erträgt das zeigte sich auch bei
der Impfpflicht vor der Wahl schloss die
FDP sie kategorisch aus frisch in der
Ampel nicht mehr alle dann die
Kehrtwende von der Kehrtwende es ist ein
Spagat zwischen regieren und eigener
Überzeugung gerade bei Thema Corona
zeigt sich ja wie wichtig die FDP in den
letzten anderthalb Jahren war einerseits
in der Opposition wo wir angemahnt haben
dass Bürgerrechte in der Rolle spielen
das Eigenverantwortung auch in so einer
Gesundheitskrise eine Rolle spielt und
dann als Regierungspartei wo wir
durchgesetzt haben dass nicht einfach
Bürgerrechte weggenommen werden das
nicht lockdowns kommen das
Schulschließung verhindert werden
Störgeräusche innerhalb der Ampel sie
selbst betonen wie sehr rot und grün sie
unter Druck setzten sie klammern sich an
alte ideale sagen Nein zu Steuererhöhung
übergewinnsteuer Tempolimit doch eine
alte fdp-größe mahnt das sei der falsche
Weg der FDP muss vermitteln dass sie
nicht stehen geblieben ist dass sie auch
nach vorne blickt dass sie nicht nur
nein sagt sie sagte oft in berechtigter
Weise nein dass sie eigene eigene
Vorschläge hat eigene Vorschläge Lindner
zerreißt heute erst einmal den Vorschlag
vom Kollegen Habeck er stellt die
gasumlage in Frage die Finanzierung
einer Alternative liefert er aber nicht
es ist auch die Kommunikation die oft
gestört erscheint
das ist wahrscheinlich der Knackpunkt
dass das jetzt gerade auch kommunikativ
nicht wirklich rüberkommt dass es eher
so rüberkommt als ob die FDP in der
Koalition
Oppositionspolitik macht nahezu und gar
nicht mal so sehr sich dafür einsetzt
die Politik so durchzusetzen wie sie es
eben im Wahlkampf letztes Jahr
versprochen hat die FDP steckt im
Existenzkampf mal wieder nicht nur in
Niedersachsen sollte dort das Ergebnis
für die FDP nicht gut ausgehen wird es
innerhalb der Ampel ganz neue
Störgeräusche geben und auch bei den
Liberalen